we are asked how does the current going
through r1 so this resistor when the
switch is open this switch compared to
the current through r1 when the switch
is closed pause this video and see if
you can figure that out
all right so let's just think about the
two scenarios so we could view the
current as this right over here this
current that we care about we could
either measure it there or you could
measure it right over there
and let's first think about the scenario
where the switch is open
so our current when our switch is open
is going to be equal to the voltage
across the resistors and that's going to
be our 12 volts
12 volts divided by the equivalent
resistance of these resistors when the
switch is open essentially we just have
r1 and r2 in series and so this is just
going to be r1 plus r2 if you have two
resistors in series their equivalent
resistance is just the sum of their
resistances
fair enough
now let's think about the situation
where the switch is closed
closed
so here our current at this point of our
circuit or the current going through r1
so
i sub closed is once again it's going to
be equal to 12 volts the voltage across
the resistors but what are we going to
divide by now
when we close the switch what happens
well these lines where we see no
resistors in circuit diagrams that's
assumed to be resistanceless
so all of the current will actually flow
that way so by closing this switch
you're essentially removing r2 from the
circuit the current will just go through
r1 and then follow the path of least
resistance literally
and so in this situation our current is
going to be 12 volt divided by you
essentially just have one resistance
divided by r1
so when you closed the circuit you've
essentially taken a resistor out and so
if you took a resistor out you're going
to increase the current
so you could just write it as
the current when the switch is open
is going to be less than
is going to be less than the current
when
the switch is closed
once again why is that well just look at
the denominators here
when the switch is open you're dividing
by a larger number than when the switch
is closed or another way of thinking
about it when the switch is open the r2
resistance is factored in when the
switch is closed the r2 resistance
essentially becomes a non-factor and you
have less resistance which would mean
you would have higher current